you think that the jokes that you're
able to tell the comedians are able to
tell you think that it's better content
now with Biden or better content when
Trump was in office
that's an interesting question because I
think that
I think that people
either they're not aware of it
or they're not willing to admit it
but I think that people are actually
happier with Biden in office and not
right or left
I think they're happier being less
engaged
everybody's been able to kind of like
disconnect a little bit and with Trump
he has this unbelievable magnetism
that
whether you like it or not you're gonna
react
the guy talks and you react
and I think what happened with that is
it went Trump
then covid
and we were just like sensory overload
and everything that we were told became
[ __ ] three weeks later you know what
I'm saying like every little bit of
information we got
was not exactly true and I don't know if
you guys went through this but I just
kind of like removed myself I was
exhaustion I'm not reading another
exhaustion bro I read an article once it
was a whole article right and like I
read and it was like you know the adds
kicking in I'm like reading and I'm like
having a hypothetical fight with my wife
she doesn't even know about and then I
gotta come back to the same of the
[ __ ] top of the article four
different times I restart the song I get
to the bottom of the article I'm like I
[ __ ] read that whole article about
some [ __ ] I don't even care about I got
this I'm a citizen of America you know
what's going on the first [ __ ] blurb
at the bottom of the article is like
some information in this article has
been refuted blah blah yeah I don't need
you to [ __ ] it yeah put it at the top
you know how many times
I'll never get that time back I have all
this new information and it's useless
wow
so I weirdly think
I think that like I think people feel
two ways I think people are probably
embarrassed about Biden I think people
are way more entertained by Trump I
think regardless of where their
political beliefs lie
and I don't care who the [ __ ] you are
everybody agrees with a little bit of
what [ __ ] Trump says and everybody
agrees a little bit of what buys there's
no person that's like I only believe the
same thing one man believe like I don't
but I don't believe if you but I think
the temperature is cooler the tricky
thing now is that
Biden's so old and so obviously dealing
with the cognitive issues cognitive bare
minimum cognitive issues right he can't
say a number that's more than four
digits yeah Hey listen Andrew two words
if it's more than four different made in
America yeah
honestly he might be more entertaining
than Trump if you really think about it
who's the best in person who doesn't
best it's Trump I mean you had Alec
Baldwin you had all these uh Frank
Caliendo who does Biden I can't even
know
[Music]
um
the face swap it's brilliant it's
brilliant how done again because he says
the same mistakes words and uh well then
yo but Andrew like real talk and Pat we
talked about this Trump a lot of people
are like man just the Santa in the truck
I saw a rally he's not done he's not
only running
coming back you don't think Trump has
the Party by the balls Pat who July
Trump oh there's no question about it
yeah because even if he even if he
doesn't win the primary he'll run as an
independent that's right there you go
that's right so if they got to give him
the nomination if they want
if they want to win and and Republicans
get organized right they get in line so
what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red are black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people were in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody saying future looks spread toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
[Music]